we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
i think the original jurassic park it
meant a lot to both of us
just like uh everybody you know who
remembers exactly where they were when
they saw jurassic park for the first
time each of us were in a cinema uh
although on opposite ends of uh the
country and you know i was 13 she was 12
and
we were watching cinema usher in a new
era really where
cgi was going to
essentially show us
what up until that point how only our
imaginations could have conceived and so
uh it was pretty extraordinary and now
that we're now that we've done jurassic
world dominion and we've been able to
share the screen with the icons of
jurassic park it it means so much more
yeah i mean it's it's a huge honor to
get to be a part of the jurassic
franchise in particular the fact that
this is the grand finale
so it's incredibly meaningful and
surreal and to be here especially now
getting to celebrate the release of this
film means all the more because this
movie was supposed to originally be
released last year and so
there's a lot of anticipation for both
audiences and for ourselves
that's a very exciting time i saw the
first jurassic park when i was 16 years
old so i was right in that place where i
was uh still a child but also a teenager
who wanted to be a filmmaker and
often times you look at the craft in the
forum and you think about it in the
context of your knowledge of filmmaking
and and what was amazing to me about
that film is that that it stripped all
that away from me and and uh it reduced
me to an eight-year-old kid and i pretty
much remain that way for the rest of the
movie
and touch
i don't remember how i celebrated but i
do remember how it felt it was
it was surreal i was really excited and
i i you know guardians of the galaxy had
not come out although we had filmed it
so i didn't know how that was going to
be received and i was just grateful that
i'd gotten another job because part of
me thought guardians of the galaxy was
going to be a huge flop just like
everyone predicted and and i was like
well at least i got another job lined up
that's cool it sounds like it could be
really good i remember talking to my
manager who's got incredible discernment
she was like boy this
this i mean this feels like it has all
of the makings of a massive
movie and the story is really great the
filmmaker's amazing you can i think this
is a this is a go and so when i when
they offered it to me and i was of
course accepting i just remember
thinking like a sense of relief you know
there's a cloud of uncertainty that
follows most actors around and that
cloud seemed to dissipate for what would
be at least a year of my life and that
was a i was really grateful for that
yeah being invited to do jurassic world
like what chris said was one of the kind
of most surreal moments of my life and i
remember
meeting
colin we did like a skype call
he told me the story of jurassic world
and i was like oh my gosh he's really
sharing like some spoilers here this is
kind of amazing
and uh and and then a few weeks later he
called me and he was at the top of a
mountain in hawaii
and and was just like hey i've been
trying to reach you because i wanted to
ask you to be in our movie and i think i
sat down very slowly i think that's kind
of what happened
how i celebrated was i sat down very
slowly i was i was pretty stunned i was
definitely stunned you know i don't
remember celebrating that i i probably
have learned since that i should
celebrate the moments along the way i
took it as a great responsibility i i
took it very seriously and uh i i don't
think that i've stopped feeling that way
about it in the nine years since that
day uh maybe now uh if people like this
movie i will finally celebrate you know
jurassic world took uh a lot of dreaming
and then a lot of
uh research on on how uh theme parks and
resorts uh have been built in the modern
world how they how they function you
know we went to universal uh you know in
in orlando and look behind the scenes at
the control room and how they actually
operated um and so we wanted to make
something that was indelible that was
iconic in its own way that felt real
because we were actually going to build
it and that set existed and at the time
i don't even know that i realized uh
how
you know rare it is uh to build a set
the size that we built when we made
jurassic world uh and now i look back on
it and i honestly i can't believe that
that uh we did it
i promise you i am gonna get her back
in the first film owen probably hoped
claire would take that stick out of her
butt
you know
and if she did she might be just the
kind of
gal he'd want to be with but at that
point in his life he'd be too scared to
be committed to her so it wouldn't have
worked out what happened over the course
of 10 years is she evolved from being a
girl who could barely hug her own
nephews to a doting mother and a
powerhouse mama action hero
and
owen turned from a guy who would have
ran from her into a guy who would do who
would run toward her and would do
anything he could to protect her the for
the relationship they have and and the
kid that they're uh bringing up as their
own so it's been an incredible arc
really for for two characters we've
watched the relationship truly evolve
over the course of of the three films
and um
it's it's been
really fun it's been an incredible eight
years
you know i i feel like i i have uh
found a lot of success casting actors
who
have a part of the character in them and
you know bryce's connection to claire
and chris's connection to owen i think
really helped
us not just create the characters in the
first place but decide how they would
change over time and and where they
would end up and
the fact that you know we all grew up
together while we were making these
movies we all have kids who are about
the same age so those two characters
evolving into parents uh who are focused
on protecting their child uh felt most
personal to us and and i i thought you
know seeing that happen over the course
of six seven years uh was something that
was just really satisfying
see not so bad
well in in jurassic world dominion the
way that colin tavaro the the director
describes it is that it was a tennis
ball free movie yes so there were a lot
of animatronic dinosaurs that we were
able to act opposite from
and that experience i mean honestly just
feels like you're in a room with a
dinosaur because it's a giant robot
operated by dozens of people
and it's it's an absolutely terrifying
and enthralling experience there's also
the preparation that is required for any
jurassic movie or i could say any action
film which is that you just you want to
be ready to take some body hits to run a
lot i mean these are these are things
that you need to be prepared to do many
many many many times
so there is the the physical preparation
aspect of it um and it was always cool
because colin would keep us very much so
in the loop as to what he was imagining
what he was writing with emily
carmichael so that we had the chance to
prepare
it's it's been exciting to see them all
you know seeing
the raptors uh and all their glory has
been amazing and dominus rex seeing what
that would look like in the final form
was really exciting obviously t-rex
the only star to have appeared in all
six films flying dinosaurs i mean it's
hard it's hard to say they're they're
all just so extraordinary in their own
way i like baby dinosaurs yeah whenever
there's a baby dinosaur i get very
excited
in this film we have dinosaurs with
feathers for the first time in the
franchise and
it was a challenge for us to really
understand how
feathers react to snow and water and
wind it is a really challenging thing
for animators
to
create for our animatronic to feel
natural and real and so a lot of
experimenting went on as we uh made a
couple dinosaurs the therazinosaurus the
pyro raptor our goal was to make it not
look like a six-foot turkey and feel
actually scary uh which i hopefully
think we did you know we told two
stories that had hybrid dinosaurs in
them and and i really wanted to make
sure that uh especially since we were
bringing uh the legacy characters back
in the spirit of jurassic park and
michael crichton that we made a science
thriller that really focused on the
paleontological record even though of
course we always are going to you know
make slight changes to account for the
fact that these dinosaurs have been you
know brought back from from dna we
wanted this to to feel like the same
kind of science thriller that jurassic
park was blue represented the the
suggestion that dinosaurs are animals
and animals and humans uh do have bonds
and can connect and so
in
the creation of
this relationship uh between owen and
blue even though characters in the movie
uh either don't understand it or even
make fun of it uh you know there is
something i think way deep down that is
is soulful and beautiful about a human
connecting with an animal i looked at
the t-rex as a character who we've known
for almost 30 years who
really needs to find a home and to find
family we've we've really never seen her
see
others like her and so
seeing her displaced in fallen kingdom
seeing her out on the run you know being
chased by helicopters and confused about
where she is i felt like we would really
want her to find her place in this world
and hopefully that's a story that we
could we could really connect to
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
well the second movie was really
designed
to set up the third movie and so it's
this interesting framework
uh because what needed to happen in the
second movie was
the island needed to be destroyed
and you needed to also
create a
story that would end in
you know planting the seed for the
proliferation of these dinosaurs that
would be the landscape that would set up
the third movie so it was it was very
much an interesting challenge for the
writers and for j.a
to deliver a movie that was structurally
really kind of unlike any of the
jurassic films that had come before and
so because of that movie we're able to
do what we're now doing in this film
which is the big payoff the big uh
question of can humans and dinosaurs
coexist not during a mishap in a theme
park in this sort of like man over
animal in a zoo type of scenario but
rather
in a world where the
pandora's box has been opened this
technology exists these animals exist
all around the world what does that look
like and can man and creature coexist
well you know fallen kingdom was
directed by j.a bayona who's a brilliant
filmmaker and i had the opportunity to
watch another director work from start
to finish and make a film and i i
learned so much from him i honestly
think i'm a better director as a result
of getting to watch him work and the
film we made there told a story that we
pay off in in uh jurassic world dominion
i i hope that once you see this movie
when you watch the whole trilogy it'll
be very clear that you know we were
telling a story the whole time
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
it was bananas to get to be in a movie
with not just laura and jeff goldblum
and sam neil but the characters they
played in the original jurassic park
this was always designed to be the
finale for not just jurassic world but
also jurassic park so there are
storylines that were established in 1993
in the original jurassic park that get
paid off in jurassic world dominion
and to get to be in the movie that does
that
is so thrilling when we were on set
there were many times when we were
like it's true like it was just as a fan
it was such a thrilling experience and i
can imagine for audiences that they're
going to feel the same way that we felt
making a movie yeah i mean it was we
were you know we were kids when we saw
this film and and they were cemented in
their minds as the icons they are and to
be able to share the screen with them
it's a delight got to not only work with
them and learn from them professionally
but also get to know each of them as
people through the course of filming
this it was an incredibly intimate
experience
given the circumstances uh under which
we we filmed this
movie and and uh yeah they're they're
even better people than they are actors
and that's that's saying a lot um
they're just fantastic and they are our
lifelong friends moving forward whether
they like it or not
uh sorry laura jeff sam you can't get
rid of us yeah we're your best friends
now
what was most interesting to us was
understanding
if any of them knew any of the others
what they thought of each other does
alan grant know that owen grady is this
guy who trained raptors
did owen grady read alan grant's book
they seem like simple questions but the
answers would really inform how each of
them would would interact and what their
dynamics would be so we figured that out
first and then we let each of our actors
in a lot of cases follow their own
instincts because i think actors are
authorities on
their characters especially if you've
been playing them as long as laura dern
has as sam neil has jeff goldblum so i
relied on on them to tell me how they
would feel and what they would do in the
case of this film we had been living
together in a hotel in the middle of a
pandemic for quite a while we you know
we were in quarantine for a bit and you
know
texting each other uh you know cat
videos from our rooms in solitary so we
knew each other pretty well and by the
time we uh got on set we knew exactly
what we wanted to do because we had been
able to spend time figuring that out
before we got there and uh we were very
prepared and we had to be because of the
situation we were in we just powered
through and i'm i'm so proud of
everybody who worked on this film uh
because they really managed to to step
up in a pretty challenging situation
i mean everything with the motorcycles
is pretty great i truly love claire
opening paddock nine and the first you
know jurassic world film running in high
heels with the flare and the glistening
sweat and just she was so sexy and
powerful and cool and it was like this
full circle moment
i love that she and she continues to
become even more badass in this movie
with like winning knife fights and you
know delivering one-liners and jumping
across alleyways from roof to roof and
you know it's it's real action hero
stuff it's just awesome that's what
stands out right now but there's so much
action it's hard to pick just one thing
yeah i've learned so much getting to
work with this guy because he is a true
action hero
and there were so many sequences that
started off basically being like a
60-second sequence and then a sequence
and then by the time chris was was done
performing it it was
an epic
uh kind of like three scene extravaganza
and he just he understands action
so innately and is constantly finding
moments for everyone else in the scene
to shine
and it's such a joy to work with him and
to and to watch him do his thing as well
two different answers uh the most
challenging was definitely the malta
sequence uh you know we
really changed the language of these
movies and the way that we shot it it
was it was handheld it was it was you
know moving at high speeds and and very
loose and uh and kind of junky and dirty
in ways that i that i was really excited
about doing uh but my favorite probably
is the scene with with claire and the
therazinosaurus because it feels like
the essence of what i love about
jurassic park it's almost silent it's
pure terror and it's a character doing
something smart in order to survive
so i would say that's the one that i
like the most
ellie settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
for me it was it was uh john michael
crichton coming to visit the set in the
first movie that's nice um
michael crichton's son who uh
when he was um
he never met his father sadly because
michael crichton died very suddenly um
while his mother was um you know
pregnant with john michael and so
getting to have him come to set and it
was the day in the first jurassic world
that we were working with the with the
dying apatosaurus and it was one of the
only animatronics that we had in the
first film
and john michael was you know young like
seven eight years old and he he came up
to the dinosaur and he said to his mom
he goes mom it's a real dinosaur it's a
real dinosaur and i just burst into
tears because
it's a legacy that his father has left
for all of us but most especially for
his own son it's it's hard to pick just
one it's been eight magnificent years
the boardwalk the boardwalk stuff was so
amazing yeah with the 800 background 800
background and the heat in new orleans
and this abandoned six flags that we had
turned into the jurassic world park
that was pretty extraordinary you know
owen and claire kissing in the middle of
all of the action
you know me throwing marty off of myself
and
like all of that boardwalk stuff was
incredible the first original writing
the that that scrambler around and being
chased by raptors through the forest and
actually riding a motorcycle through the
jungles in hawaii at like two in the
morning in a night shoot that was just
remember when we were smoking cigars all
day on set that was fun remember the
back of the was it an atv or something
and that yeah that you were driving and
it was like down this hill and i was
like oh my god this is so fun this is so
fun and chris goes do you feel safe and
i was like yeah chris was driving he
goes good because you're not
that's true i was like
you're like this is dangerous this is
neighbors
getting stuck in the car that was fun oh
yeah
yeah
they had this was it a bmw
it was a mercedes yeah mercedes yeah it
was like this new car this mercedes car
and and they they sent out like security
literally would not let this car be seen
because it was some new
super special car that you know whatever
gives it
and uh we're stuck in this car and
and uh every helicopter would go by and
anytime
anytime they would say cut they would
come wrap the car
in like a big black cloth
and unless we got out of the car
immediately we would get trapped inside
of the car in a big black cloth in the
middle of the hawaiian heat so
they're like cut and they just like
legit wrapped us in the car and so we
had to sit there
and wait until the next shot and while
we're sweating our butts off because
they couldn't uh bother to let us out in
time to cover their precious car
remember on the um the eternity beach
from here
[Music]
yeah we laid on the beach where from
here to eternity was shot and it was
just fantastic and we got sand in our
ears so we had to lay back and be like
oh i'm so exhausted and the water is
coming up but it's like creating this
slush of sand that would literally fill
our ears and then like keep your head
down keep your head down in the water
that was rough yeah a little
waterboarding for i have a lot of
different answers for that but i would
say probably at the end of all of it we
had all of uh
all of our characters uh in the finale
of this film um when they're all packed
into the helicopter at the very end uh
that was the last thing we did we put
them in a tiny little space and i could
see all of their faces uh alongside each
other and i
i was just so grateful that we made it
to that point that we actually had a
movie that we could now share with the
rest of the world and get people to come
back to theaters together to see um it
was very emotional and it's definitely
not something i'm gonna forget
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right the last day on set
for of uh jurassic world dominion was a
very special day because the entire cast
was together and that's something that
we had all been looking forward to we
had experienced a bit here and there but
that last final sequence was absolutely
epic and it's when the two
two and then three dinosaurs are
are fighting yeah agreed epic jeff
goldblum recited a poem uh that we do
have footage of and you'll you'll see it
someday it's on the blu-ray but with
everyone in the in uh packed together uh
he
beautifully uh
encapsulated how we all felt with poetry
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother well i
think when you see the film you'll
you'll see how important she is and and
i i found isabella's performance in this
movie to be so beautiful and and what
what mattered to us the most is that
we've put a human face on this sense of
displacement and the sense of of
searching for an identity of you know
who am i if there if there was another
who was genetically identical to me and
all of those questions you know we asked
in fallen kingdom and i hope we answered
them in a satisfying way here emily
carmichael my co-writer on this uh was
really instrumental in
really figuring out exactly what story
we wanted to tell when it comes to to
maisie and her history and it's one of
the things i'm most proud of in this
movie
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
well
in a lot of ways uh
dr wu is is the most important character
he's the one who created uh this
technology john hammond was you know he
used to run a circus he's a showman and
but this is the genius who feels as if
he he actually didn't receive the credit
that he deserves and i think that that
need for recognition has driven him to
to keep pushing it and make a lot of you
know
really not so good decisions and in this
film he's gone a bit too far and he's
making this he's made a decision that
threatens the entire planet and i really
wanted him to have a moment of
redemption and a place where he really
has to decide you know which side of the
line is he gonna fall on and in this
film he makes a choice
that's another plane right
not exactly
well look the only thing that makes for
a perfect jurassic park movie is
jurassic park and i think once you
accept that and you know that that you
know as a filmmaker your goal is to to
take something that is a perfectly
tended garden and then plant something
new respecting uh the foundation that
that movie was built on and it was built
on science and it was built on a
question asked by michael crichton uh
about our our place in this world and
our responsibility uh
in the shadow of of nature and and its
power and hopefully we've asked that
question in this film in a way that that
honors uh what he did
well you know it is the end of an of
this story that we've been telling and
at the end of these six movies uh and
yet in this film it was really important
to us to introduce new characters and
new heroes that fans and and especially
the next generation can
can uh want to follow and i'm i'm
confident they will so for me
i know that there's a young filmmaker
out there who has the passion for this
uh that i have and that i had eight or
nine years ago that'll see this new
world that we've created and know what
story uh there is to tell so whoever you
are if he or she is out there we're
listening i think i i think i've told my
story i think i've told my story i think
it's it's good to pass the torch i had
the torch pass to me and i think it's my
responsibility to pass it to somebody
else
you